[Aplausos]
escolhi um tema que eu tenho pensado
bastante eu adoro tecnologia e se a
gente parar para observar cada vez mais
as tecnologias estão conseguindo se
atualizar automaticamente existem botões
que você pode apertar para deixar um
auto update então por exemplo se você
tem no seu telefone alguns aplicativos e
você pode falar pro próprio telefone
configurar para se atualizar
automaticamente até mesmo carros hoje em
dia quem conhece o novo tese um belo dia
as pessoas que tinham o tempo acordaram
e ele estava dirigindo sozinho pra
garagem
então agora já tem carro se atualizando
automaticamente por software mas a gente
como ser humano em um mundo que tem
mudado tanto como a gente pode se auto
atualizado automaticamente deixa eu
explicar um pouquinho essa ideia porque
parece um pouco mirabolante a cada
minuto a gente está aprendendo mas às
vezes a gente está com uma chave ligada
ou com a chave e desligada
como a gente pode sem perceber de forma
automática consegui nos atualizarmos a
cada instante e transformar cada
instante é uma boa oportunidade para
aquilo que a gente mais quer na nossa
vida
o muro tem mudado tão rápido que eu
tomei pra mim
a missão junto à minha equipe de
conseguir trabalhar como as pessoas
aprendem de forma diferente como as
pessoas pensam de forma diferente e
principalmente como as pessoas aplicam
aquilo que elas aprendem naquilo que
elas mais querem realizar na vida isso é
que as empresas fazem e eu tenho pensado
muito como eu posso então trazer isso
pra minha vida eu tenho algumas
premissas que eu levo pra isso e é isso
que eu quero compartilhar com vocês hoje
a primeira coisa o poder do vínculo e
nesse momento eu quero pedir uma
permissão que a permissão que eu tenho
pedido ultimamente pra conseguir me
atualizar mais rapidamente a permissão
pra ser intensa o que acontece
às vezes a gente fica cheio de dedos e
não estou dizendo intenso de forma
grosseira de forma direta
eu estou dizendo intenso de uma forma
que você consegue ser intensamente
conectado com a sua verdade se você
consegue ser intensamente conectado com
a sua verdade quando você está numa
reunião quando você está numa palestra
como eu tô aqui você consegue passar com
muito mais clareza aquilo que é
autêntico pra você e desde coisas que
parecem pequenas como quando a gente vai
numa entrevista de emprego e não
consegue ser intenso perante aquilo que
você acredita e acaba no lugar errado
até coisas muito mais importantes como
quando você não consegue encontrar
paixão por aquilo que você está fazendo
não consegue criar um vínculo naquilo
para continuar seguindo em frente quando
está tudo difícil eu acredito muito no
poder do veículo e o vínculo é
importante em diversas diversas diversas
em diversos lugares existem diversas
pesquisas inclusive que é bem
interessante quanto mais vínculo uma
pessoa tem com coisas que ela realmente
ama mais liberdade ela tem pra conseguir
se virar naquilo que ela mais ama
isso parece irônico mas isso é muito
muito poderoso
então quero permissão para ser intensa
com vocês hoje eu quero permissão para
falar com vocês hoje como talvez nunca
mais se você falar como se talvez fosse
morrer hoje mais tarde e se extremamente
honesta perante o que eu penso que tenha
permissão beleza então vamos nessa
segunda coisa que eu sempre penso tem a
ver com buscar as coisas que já existem
no mundo
mas olhando para aquilo e dentro daquilo
tirando alguma coisa que serve pra você
tem coisas que batem direto no nosso
coração tem coisas que nos tiram da zona
de conforto mas sempre tem alguma coisa
que você pode tirar pra você
o poder da observação é algo incrível e
eu gosto muito de observar inclusive
como as pessoas se atualizam eu quero
dar dois exemplos para vocês
existem pessoas extremamente intensas
que gostam de verdade para os extremos e
uma vez no ano passado neste e num
programa que ficava uma semana sem comer
tomando soccoro fila e meu ponto aqui
que não precisa ficar uma semana aqui
sem comer tomando toda a fila
mas existem pessoas que gostam de
aprender nos extremos
você precisa aprender os extremos não
mas observando como essas pessoas
aprendem e pegando talvez componentes
aquilo você pode trazer isso pra você
hoje foi muito falado sobre crianças
aqui crianças são fascinantes porque se
vocês repararem elas têm um mecanismo
que ela se atualizam sempre elas estão
sempre buscando alguma coisa e se você
for parar para observar
elas são sempre se auto desafiando estão
sempre meio que altos saindo da zona de
conforto ela não sabe a resposta elas
não têm medo
elas vão lá tentam procurar uma resposta
deu errado continuam provocando aquela
resposta e muitas vezes juntas as
crianças como criam um é muito
interessantes
então você consegue olhar para
diferentes mundos e não necessariamente
copiar aquele mundo pra você mas
procurar uma outra coisa que existe
naquele mundo que possa ser aplicado pra
você não descarte diretamente às vezes a
gente pensar aquilo não é pra mim aquilo
não é pra mim em vez de simplesmente
jogar dessa maneira
olha com olhar de aprendizado com aquele
olhar encantado que pode encontrar
alguma coisa nas entrelinhas que pode
ser interessante para sua vida
o terceiro ponto eu quero falar pra
vocês têm a ver com hierarquiza são zero
vou explicar esse é um pouquinho melhor
claro que no dia a dia a gente tem que
ter prioridades não dá tempo de fazer
tudo o que a gente quer fazer
porém as pessoas pegam em olhar para um
momento da semana achando que é mais
importante do que o outro olhar para uma
idéia e descartá lo achando que é menos
importante do que outra ou então pensar
que uma pessoa pode ser menos relevante
pra você do que outra isso acontece em
tantos tantos momentos quem é que não
tem um amigo que você abrir com o
facebook no começo da semana é a segunda
de manhã e seu amigo postou sexta vem
neném ouve o que tapa na cara da segunda
terça quarta e quinta
nessa segunda terça quarta e quinta
também a vida eu também vejo muitas
pessoas às vezes em eventos que eles têm
um evento que querem ver uma outra
pessoa e no meio do caminho conhecem
alguém só que daquela pessoa fica
atônita porque não era quem queria
esse e não consegue estar presente no
presente e às vezes perde uma baita
oportunidade de conhecer melhor pessoa
para ela fora iraquização de idéias
eu acho que a pior de todas se você
hierarquia idéias você tá perdida tem
uma história interessante no livro que
gosta bastante que se chama
oportunidades disfarçadas
aliás eu adoro esse conceito de
oportunidades passadas no qual o carlos
domingos que o autor conta que tinha uma
indústria que precisava ser reinventada
não estavam fechando as contas por causa
do preço daquele produto então todos
executivos foram recrutados para uma
reunião de emergência para conseguir
encontrar alguma ideia genial pra
conseguir tirar aquela indústria do
problema que estava vivendo
a ideia tem ideia fai nada tava saindo
até que tinha alguém que estava
simplesmente na verdade varrendo o chão
da reunião que perguntou eu produto
precisa mesmo de embalagem e daí como
muitas vezes de idéias são realizadas o
olhar e falar é claro que precisa
descartaram a idéia
só que uma pessoa velha frase não tava
lá pra lá vamos pensar nisso se ela que
precisa mesmo de embalagem
o produto em questão eram pneus pneus
algumas décadas atrás tinham embalagens
para diferenciar o produto e depois
houve essa cara de que você podia
colocar muitas informações do pneu no
próprio pneu
a verdade é todo momento é muito
importante toda pessoa que você conhece
é muito importante todo dia que aparece
pode virar uma ideia muito importante e
se você começa a hierarquizar os seus
momentos a hierarquizar sua vida você
perde a chance de viver aquele momento
a gente sabe que às vezes alguns
momentos cruciais da nossa vida a gente
só repara que eles eram cruciais quando
a gente olha para trás e fala nossa que
momento crucial
agora imagina aquele momento crucial não
fosse vivido
imagina se você naquele momento melhor
ainda por estar vivendo intensamente
repara no momento que é um momento
crucial e consegue fazer o melhor dele
enquanto ele acontece
é isso que acontece quando a gente não
irar 15 o tempo então é muito muito
importante que a gente não ir a 15 eu
gosto muito de aprender inclusive sobre
todos os assuntos
é uma das coisas que mais me ajuda em
tudo
os meus negócios é uma curiosidade
aguçada de querer sempre aprender
independente daquele assunto
esse assunto super mistificar nesse
assunto é criatividade que parece que só
alguns são criativos criatividade a
questão de repertórios e que ser
criativo escuta todo mundo com o mesmo
interesse e tenta aprender com todo
mundo para criar um repertório pra você
gerar conexões entre coisas que parecem
desconexos
é isso que vai diferenciar de verdade
então hierarquiza são de momentos de
pessoas de assuntos não tá com nada não
vai fazer você conseguir se atualizar
melhor
uma outra coisa que eu sempre levo
comigo tem a ver com se permitir você
vai aprender diversas coisas que vão te
tirar daquele senso comum que você tinha
eu sou engenheira eletrônica e sentido
da computação por formação eu sou super
técnica começou na carreira programando
e agora tem uma escola e trabalho com
educação e gosta do lado comportamental
muito eu era super cética quanto aquilo
se eu por causa de égua por causa de
qualquer outra coisa falar se eu não
posso permitir que o recriminou mundo eu
ia perder tanto nessa vida você precisa
permitir que seu mundo seja recriado
quando você aprende alguma coisa que faz
sentido mudar aquilo como estava sendo
visto antes
isso é muito importante inclusive
vulnerabilidade é algo muito importante
quando você se mostra vulnerável
não é algo para se ter vergonha
interessantes está mostrando que tem a
humildade de crescer
o problema se você não tenha humildade
para crescer daí você está de novo
porque ninguém claro chegou no lugar que
nunca mais aparecer então
vulnerabilidade recriar o seu mundo em
busca da sua melhor versão isso é muito
muito muito importante
agora quando eu falo tudo isso você tem
que pegar e buscar o que funciona para o
seu mundo
eu tô dando aqui alguns exemplos que pra
mim funciona
eu acho muito importante que quando você
decidir se quer fazer ou você faz aquilo
de uma maneira grande ou cai fora e tem
outra coisa agora fazer de uma maneira
grande é um conceito único a cada um
cada um tem uma maneira de olhar o que é
grande pra alguma pessoa grande pode ser
criar uma empresa que toca um bilhão de
pessoas para outra pessoa pode ser
a mãe do mundo pra outra pode ser essas
duas coisas
o ponto é que tem que respeitar o que é
o grande da outra pessoa você não pode
menosprezar o que o grande de outra
pessoa e se você não achou o seu grande
você precisa achar o seu grande porque
você tem mil razões para não fazer
alguma coisa hoje você tem mil razões se
as suas razões para fazer algo não
estiverem claras você não vai continuar
fazendo você vai desistir
então o que você quer e porque você tem
que estar muito claro se não seu grande
da sua maneira
nunca vai ser realizado o meu grande eu
tenho um pessoal e profissional foram na
verdade os dois últimos exemplos que eu
dei na vida profissional eu tenho um
sonho muito grande de que as nossas
empresas toque 1 bilhão de vidas como a
gente quer trocá las ajudando as pessoas
a darem passos em direção aos seus
sonhos é isso que a gente faz esse que a
gente quer continuar fazendo a gente
tocou 30 milhões de pessoas nos últimos
cinco anos tem muito mais para fazer mas
a gente tá sempre aquele sonho no sonho
de conseguir alcançar o wamu grande
não vamos desistir vamos grande mas eu
tenho o meu porque isso é muito
importante pra mim
agora todo ano tem sempre uma pergunta
que aquela que eu mais levo comigo
sempre levo comigo e esse ano a pergunta
que mais ficou na minha cabeça é o que
fica de tudo que a gente faz
tá bom vamos assumir o que eu falei aqui
é verdade que a gente entende que a
gente tem a nossa porque a gente sabe o
que fazer quem sabe o que é o grande
você faz um monte de coisa a gente está
aqui de que não tem pão pra aprender um
monte de coisa o que fica o que vai
ficar depois desse dia é muito
importante que você consiga aplicar
aquilo que você aprende naquilo que é
mais relevante pra você
as pessoas têm um milhão de artifícios
produtividade mas não aplicam o que
aprendem que é o mais importante ou
descartar aquilo que não funciona é
muito importante
nem eu acho que hoje em dia ninguém mais
reconstruir o império a gente construir
um legado pra gente consegue construir
um legado
você precisa parar pra pensar em como
tudo que você vive pode aplicar para te
ajudar na construção desse legado porque
todos nós já temos acesso a muitas
coisas que podem ajudar a gente
construir esse legado agora a gente só
vai conseguir fazer isso a gente for
prático
eu vejo muita gente urinando vejo muita
gente reclamando em 3d agindo tem alguma
coisa que você não gosta tenta mudar não
conseguiu
só que também não tá te influênciando
desde um pouquinho pra lá em vez de
gastar seu tempo reclamando daquilo e
foca no que você pode influenciar
positivamente para quem sabe depois
influência aquilo também as próprias
premissas que eu falei que eu levo
comigo se eu não for prática eu achar
que todas são impossíveis eu achar
problema em tudo as premissas que você
vai encontrar pra você
se você não for prático você vai travar
não vai fazer nada então é muito
importante que a gente seja prático
agora uma coisa pra mim é bem
interessante é que quando a gente fala e
eu conseguir constantemente me atualizar
não é algo que eu faço sozinha é algo
que eu faço com todo mundo e aqui a
gente está num ambiente perfeito para
todos se ajudarem juntos a ser
atualizada e já está acontecendo está
acontecendo na troca do palco com a
platéia da platéia com o palco mas eu
quero que aconteça na troca de todo
mundo com todo mundo
então eu convido vocês a fazer o
seguinte quando vocês saírem daqui
acessem em ponto com ponto br barra o
que aprendi
deixe lá uma sacada que você teve hoje
que é um aprendizado que pode ser útil
para alguma coisa e essa plataforma
colaborativa vai estar disponível para
todo mundo ver sacadas
as mais votadas a gente vai transformar
num livro colaborativo gratuito
produzido em diversas línguas feito hoje
aqui por vocês e essa é a minha visão de
como através do mundo da escrita a gente
pode se atualizar junto existe kroton
sorte existe qualquer fã dem não existe
não existe ainda cloud publishing todo
mundo publicando junto aquilo que tem
sido mais bem aplicado para a sua vida e
essa é a minha visão pra mim editora a
gente que será a maior plataforma de
cloud publishing do mundo é que
encontrar as melhores pessoas do mundo
para descobrir o que elas aprenderam o
que elas podem também agregar para que
você possa aprender o que você pode
compartilhar com outras pessoas para que
todos possam crescer cada vez um
quando você tiver vendendo pede
permissão para ser intensa procura de
verdade a razão que você tem pra fazer
algo que tem muita razão para não fazer
algo tenha muito clara a razão pra você
fazer algo e eu estou louca para ver
quais foram as sacadas que vocês tiveram
aqui porque eu tive muitas em cada uma
das palestras
eu sempre pensa que por ventura tem 20
pessoas estão aqui no palco mas se cada
um de vocês com ansiedade a chance de
estar aqui vocês tenham algo incrível
para compartilhar com a gente então
obrigada por cada um que está aqui hoje
e obrigada pela oportunidade de dividir
um pouco do meu mundo com você
valeu valeu
[Aplausos]